it's gonna be awkward to play a game
like this but we move this over like
that okay I'm back
this is gonna be a very quick stream
okay people see the time more
importantly can people see that the hug
okay I'm gonna play just one game and
then I'm gonna end the stream I just
wanted to make this guy a bit more a bit
more famous on the Internet it's playing
out of six here attack the pong plays
Knight c3 this could actually transpose
into some sort of open Sicilian which
I'd be happy with the Queen c7 at some
point he'll probably play d4 unless he
wants to be passive in play d3 now I'm
not using my usual microphone so I don't
know how well the computer will pick up
the volume or the sound but every time
this guy takes a breath he makes kind of
a annoying noise so spare with us a 485
because this setup is the passive pawn
on d3 Bishop on you - not the best
harmony so he plays G for it makes sense
I'm gonna play c4
you
an idea is to keep restricting the
bishop at some point he might play b3 if
he wants to take on c4 of discovery
checks out like there should be seven he
might just play this path one which
looks okay okay now he wants to take and
then take ninety five so I'll play
Bishop d6 hello too far toss and now and
hello to Nathan at three one four how's
it going yeah this is going to be the
quickest dream that I've probably ever
done
so I'm just playing one game
and the plug is going to be probably a
hindrance but maybe a good luck charm
hello tip Akash Akasha Prakash
there's no you after that cute
this is actually interesting he's
debating whether to take on d5 she does
which I kind of kind of forgot about
that's probably a very strong move
because if I take he takes with the
check and he's winning back the piece
there should be 655 out that's what I
get for not casting soon enough
there's no Simon did I mention a Simon
the title should be streaming with a pug
oh did I not update okay that the
entitle should be updated I'm in trouble
here
with Daddy string John Bartholomew wants
to play me on chess comm did he say that
or are you just saying
um I mean let's try and survive this
position this is bad
maybe I'm just losing upon I'll give
back the piece he's gonna take on c4 we
checked I play 97 and then I'll Castle
I'm just down the piece or down a pawn
I'm down upon but I have a plug so
compensation what is it with the message
we get and your vibe
wait what Simon's and five minutes
something
oh no I see it's all go alive
notification I never meant to have that
I think I meant to post that it's like a
status and not like a go live
notification my bad sorry for any
confusion I just got rid of that hello
to dishonest John I hope that's an
honest hello I'm gonna just be down the
pond now actually there's a scenario in
chess when you're down material the
obstacle or Bishop situation usually
gives you some hope because it needs to
positions where there's drawing chances
also these positions where there's
better chances to attack especially if I
can like we can find darts raised on the
Kings side that might be hard to do I'm
gonna continue to move what I want to do
though d5 looks fun swimming over Thank
You Nathan for subbing for two months in
a row appreciate that and hello to
Gabriel
lots of people here already those in
this dope I'll take that as a good thing
I mean Rick h5 is somewhat extravagant
but I mean I want to attack
maybe I mean really the idea is to use
all the pieces to try and attack the
kingside question is where do I targets
or what to targets on because each twos
defended it's hard to attack another
time eat Belle Plaine I teach for coming
up I have to be careful of discoveries
but currently his Knights tied down so
that's a good thing
uh-uh oh thanks for the chip 13 bits
Nathan F leaving a leaderboard 95 ok
obstructing the Queen attacking the rook
but now the Knights pins that my lips
attacked I could play now tat for these
for page six you'll just leave my rook
on each six so now the Knights attack
three times
well now it's defended twice but that
force hanging sheet I was a free pawn so
now it's equal material I can move that
the might still pins oh but he has a
strong move here maybe yeah he's a
really strong move 96 was bad I should
have taken the shirt 87 might also be
strong I was more scared of this I play
that max I've repeat though the bishop
is attacking Knights attack this is
really complicated
maybe I'm winning with pawn back take
take take f7 could fall in the end
that's sure if he's snoring
he's just breathing he's away
women I just take it mine Queen c5 chat
oh that doesn't do anything not like
take two to be Tuesday and some lines
aha chess is so complicated I have to
take on e5 just debating what to take
with maybe it doesn't matter tape of
thanks because he's gonna do this tactic
to win a seventh on I guess he could he
could take on a seven with either piece
or take money five first but whatever
happens I wouldn't need to in the end
unless he defends me too
what you're doing Doug
okay so we're trading Queens and then
it's still on down upon but at least
it's an open position the Brooke is
doing stuff on the second rank
I have to block and I'm fighting for a
draw because I'm down upon what's your
dog's name this dog's name is Luca but
it's not my dog
um it's a friend's dog and I'm in San
Francisco right now so this is my new
location for the next four to five days
okay take one c3
trying to think from an objective
standpoint if this is like a GM game I'm
pretty sure it's just a draw but from a
practical standpoint it might be tricky
are you going to the two sale honks oh
you'll be a PCL final so yeah I'll be
there I'll be there as a reporter for HS
life or mainly a photographer and I
might do like the I'll do photos for
chess life and then maybe some social
media through that's Jess okay I can't
take and I can't move I came to an open
thought oh that could be an issue I like
to play like five
it's a scary looking position at some
point he might play workout fade now my
Kings really active he's gonna put his
work on each for all kinds King off
he'll do that now that's just a draw but
it's gonna come down to time let's cut
his King off my king was very active
let's cut this thing off more what is he
doing I don't know what he's doing now I
could try and infiltrate maybe start
with this I'm going to march it like on
I do have to pay attention to time
though why does he move his King so far
away very confusing like a trade oh no
it's just a draw don't play h4 don't
play h4 in plate or yes now I'm winning
this I think what can I win in time
it's hard to pre move with a plug on
your lap hey I won okay wait what was
that ending was that winning that was
winning this is a classic King pawn
ending like everyone should know when
you attack the pawn and you can continue
to attack and then defend upon what
happens is we get this Mutual's of long
position and this is a type of position
if it's your move you lose but if it's
your opponent's move you in so if you
played h4 it's just to draw I think
that's the only drawing move here cuz
h4g for the h1 can start running then we
just have to trade okay that was a very
quick stream I have to go I have stuff
to do today we're gonna I'll probably be
back I might stream tomorrow during the
protesting finals because it's sponsored
by twitch but if I stream tomorrow it'll
probably be on chess calm because the
events
being posted on chest comm so I will see
you guys later
yeah that was a quickest stream ever
less than 12 minutes okay see you guys